c'est une séquence totalement folle on y
voit sate le fils de 6 ans de Kim et du
rappeur Kanye West joué avec l'iPad
familial quand soudain
oui il tombe sur une publicité pour la
sextape de sa maman et la starlette de
fondera larmes au téléphone avec gagner
bon c'est pas très drôle mais quand même
un peu hein
[Rires]
c'est chaud ça oui je suis désolé on va
pas pleurer pour elle c'est les limites
de l'argent facile en fait c'est pour ça
qu'il faut dire à tous les jeunes
aujourd'hui qui sont tentés de vendre
des contenus dénudés
ne le faites pas parce que les images
elles restent et les gens sont certes
contre vous mais attends
c'était totalement commercial depuis le
début j'ai sa mère qui aurait tout ça
ils l'ont mis en vente
c'est pas découvre pas la sexualité
sans nom elle est absolument pas choqué
que son fils et vu les images c'est un
énorme contrat qu'ils ont signé avec
Lulu et il faut tout relancer il faut
relancer la dynamique Kardashian créer
plein d'intrigues donc évidemment là tu
vois bien qu'elle fait semblant de
pleurer de toute façon elle se doute
bien en ayant fait des sextape et on a
commercialisant qu'à un moment donné
c'est 14 gosses vont tomber dessus c'est
normal c'est dur pour les enfants
départ de tout la sextelle c'est comme
ça qu'on l'a connu et moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est qu'en fait de Guillaume
dit oui mais tu t'adresses aux jeunes il
faut pas je suis désolé mais c'est hyper
tentant de faire une sextape et de
devenir kim Kardashian et voilà tu t'es
déjà posé la question
donc les photos il y avait des photos de
quoi qui circulent
la vérité l'autre fois on nous a demandé
s'il y avait des Polaroid
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans toutes les belles rencontres
[Musique]
[Rires]
si je peux me permettre